[موسيقى]
في اجراء ان عقابيا جديد وغير مسبوغ ضد
روسيا بهدف تقليس قدرتها على تمويل حربها
في اوكرانيا شرعت مجموعه الدول السبعه
الكبرى وال الاتحاد الاوروبي واستراليا في
تنفيذ حظر على واردات النفط المنقوله بحرا
من روسيا اعتبارا من هذا الاسبوع الحضر
ياتي بعد قرار بفرض سقف سعري على النفط
الروسي عند 60 دولار للبرميل وهو القرار
الذي رفضته روسيا معلنه عدم بيع نفقها
للدول التي ستقطع لها ومحضره من تداعياته
على دول اخرى فما هي فرص نجاح هذه القيود
الجديده على صديرات النفط الروسيه وكيف
ستتعامل معها موسكو للتقليل من فاعليتها
ومنع اكاساتها وتاثيراتها المحتمله على
اسواق طاقه العالميه المطربه اصلا اهلا
بكم في هذه الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم حرب الطاقه
مع دخول القرار تحديد السقف لسعر النفط
الروسي حيز التنفيذ اعتبارا من الاثنين
الماضي لم يعد مسموحه لشركات الشحن في
الاتحاد الاوروبي نقل النفط الروسي الا
اذا كان مباحا بالسعر الاقصى الذي حددته
مجموعه السبع الاوروبي وليس بالسعر الذي
تحدده السوق وفقا لمنطق العرض والطلب كما
هو معروف ومتداول عن هذه الخطوه الجديده
في حرب الطاقه المستعره وكيف سترد عليها
روسيا وارتدادات ذلك على اسواق النفط
العالميه في المدنيين القصير والبعيد
يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في هذه الحلقه من
موسكو المحل السياسي الروسيه
من عمان عامر الشوبكي الخبير في شؤون
النفط والطاقه ومن لندن الدكتور
الاقتصاد في جماعه معهد العلوم السياسيه
في باريس والخبير الدولي في طيب
الاقتصاد الروسي يعتمد بشكل كبير على
مداخله صادراته من النفط والغاز اذ تمثل
نسبه
20.2% من الناتج القومي الاجمالي للبلاد
وفقا لاحصاءات الربع الثاني من هذا العام
وتملك روسيا ثالثا اكبر احتياطيا نفط في
العالم ويقدر ب 80 مليار برميل وتعد خمسه
اكبر منتج له بحوالي 11 مليون برميل في
اليوم يصدر ونصفها نحو الخارج ويعتمد
المجهود الحربي الروسي في اوكراني بشكل
كبير على هذه المداخيل اذ تساهم في
ميزانيه الدوله بنسبه
45% ويبلغ سعره خام الاورال الروسي حاليا
حوالي 65 دولار للبرميل اي انه اعلى من
سقف الاسعار المحدد مؤخرا ب 50 دولارات
فقط ما سيجعل تاثير الاجراءات الاوروبي
محدودا على الاقتصاد الروسي في الامد
القصير ويخشى خبراء اقتصادي في العالم
تاثير اجراء التسقيف على السوق العالميه
للطاقه وكذلك دفع الاسعار الى التضخم اكثر
[موسيقى]
جبهه جديده تفتحها العقوبات الغربيه على
النفط الروسي انها نذر اضطرابات لا تعرف
حدودها حتى الان في سوق النفط العالميه في
روسيا هي ثالث اكبر منتج للنفط الخام بعد
الولايات المتحده والسعوديه وثاني اكبر
مصدر لله لن تقدم شركات الشحن والتامين
على نقل النفط من روسيا عبر البحر ما لم
يقوم بالسعر المحدد في العقوبات الغربيه
ولان العديد من شركات الشحن الكبرى موجوده
في الدول التي فرضت العقوبات فعلى الروسي
البحث عن مخارج من هذا المنزل حسب وزير
الخارجيه روسي
توصلت الى اتفاقيات مباشره مع شركاء
سيتجاهلون الحدود القصوى التي فرضتها دول
غربيه على سعر الروسيه في صداره الدول
التي يعنيها لافروف نجد الصين والهند وهما
اكبر مشتريين منفردين للنفت الروسي وتضاف
اليهما تركيا لكن ذلك لن كونك فيها وسائل
اعلام الروسيه ذكرت ان موسكو تدرس اليه
للرده تشمل خيارات عده لعل اهمها خفض
الانتاج النفطي لكن يرجح ان لا يكون بدرجه
كبيره اضافه الى حظر مبيعات النفط لبعض
الدول التي ايدت تحديد سقف لاسعاره ووضع
حد اقصى للخصم الذي ستبيع به نفتح الخام
امام موسكو الان تحديات كثيره اهمها نقل
نفدها الخام عبر البحر ذكرت صحيفه فاينل
تايمز انها كونت ما سمته اسطول ظل من 100
ناقله بتروليه لتعويض شركات الشحن البحريه
التابعه للدول الغربيه لكن محللين نتحدث
للصحيفه رجحوا انها بحاجه الى 200 ناقله
للحفاظ على صادراتها الحاليه
الذكاء الصناعي المتخصصه في النقل البحري
ويندوز فان روسيا استبقت القيود الغربيه
على نفقها
انتقلت ملكيه 180 ناقله الروسيه الى
كيانات غير روسيا منذ بدء حربها على
اوكرانيا كما بيعت ناقله الروسيه كثيره
لكيانات غير روسيه تقع مقرات اغلبها في
سنغافوره وتركيا والامارات والنرويج
نرحب بضيوفنا الثلاثه ونبدا من موسكو
سيدروف الان ماذا يمكن لموسكو ان
تسقيفه على نفقها المشحون بحرا
تحياتي لك ولساده المشاهدين والفاكهه
الكريمين انا اعتقد بها النبي ان كان
موسكو خيارات سعيده وربما اهمها طبعا يكمن
ويتمثل في زياده
صادراتها من النفط الى الدول التي ذكرت
الان في التقرير في مقدمتها بتربيه الحال
الهند والصين وهناك احصائيات او ارقام
اخيره صدرت مؤخرا وتفيد باند روسيا في
الفتره الاخيره
الامر الذي ربما ياتي تعويضا عن بعض
الخسائر المحتمله التي يمكن ان تتكبرها
روسيا جراء تحديد هذا السقف الذي يقدر
بستين دولارا مقابل برميل واحد طبعا هناك
الى جانب ذلك خيارات اخرى وربما طرق كفيله
بالالتفاف على
هذا السقفه المقدر بستين دولار
كان كيف سوف تقوم الروسيا يعني ربما هذه
الامور او هذه المخارج همم حتى الان روسيا
لا تكشف عن كل خطتها لكي لا تكون بحوزه
الدول الاوروبيه التي ربما سوف تفكر في
مزيد ومزيد من العقوبات على روسيا لا سيما
في هذا المجال في قطاع النفط الذي يعتبر
بالفعل قطاعا حساسه بالنسبه الى الاقتصاد
الروسيه ولكن همم يعني تلخيصا لما قلته
يمكن القول ان روسيا همم الان همم مستعده
وجاهزه للتعامل مع وقايه جديده همم على
ضوء مثل هذا التثقيف وبالتالي همم امامها
خيارات ستجه اليها في حاله الضروره وتعتمد
اساسا همم اما على الحلفاء القدامى انساها
تعبير منها الهندسيه وتركيا وبعض الدول
الاخرى او حصل ربما عن شركاء جدد وزبائن
جدد لنفط الروسيه يمكن اللجوء اليها في
حاله الضروره ويبدو ان روسيا بدا ت- تتحرك
في هذا الاتجاه اذا كانت روسيا بدات
التحرك في هذا الاتجاه دكتور بروسلي في
لندن هل من ضمانه للدول التي اتخذت هذا
القرار بان فعلا سيجد طريقه للتطبيق بدون
اي اشكال
واننا نقوم بذلك لم ان روسيا همم هي
الثانيه
على نفس المستوى التصدير كما هو السعوديه
وبالتالي
فانا اوروبا تحتاج هذا المنتجات الروسيه
ولكن روسيا ايضا يمكن ان تبيعها خارج
المنطقه
سعره منخفضا هل سينجحون في ذلك لا اعرف
لانه روسيا لديها خياران اول هما التوقف
ايقاف التدفق هذا سؤدي الى ارتفاع اسعار
النفط بشكل كبير مفيده لمجموعته مع روسيا
او يمكن ان تعوض ذلك
عن طريق
الاستراتيجيه وهذه استراتيجيه قد
ولا نعرف كيف تطورت تستمر هل هل هذه
الخيارات سيد عامر شوبكي في عمان هل هذه
الخيارات التي ذكرت لحد الان سهله التطبيق
بالنسبه لروسيا
تحيه لك يا استاذ محمد ولضيوفك اعتقد
بانها صعبه التطبيق على روسيا بالنسبه
لقدرتها على تخفيض انتاجها هنالك
العقوبات التي يعني لمست عصب الاقتصاد
الروسي اي تخفيض على انتاج روسيا من النفط
سيؤدي بالتالي الى تخفيض ايراداتها التي
تعتمد عليها اعتقد بنسبه اكثر من 50% خاصه
مع العقوبات على المجالات الاخرى بالنسبه
للاقتصاد الروسي ايضا ليس لروسيا قدره على
استعاده انتاجها اذا ما قررت تخفيض
انتاجها
يعني صعوبات في الانتاج في المرحله
القادمه ايضا لدى روسيا اعتقد خيارات اخرى
غير هذه الخيارات ربما تلج اليها ما زالت
تزود اوروبا بسبعه ونصف من حاجتها من
الغاز قطع تقطعه عن اوروبا
طبعا زياده الضغط على القاره الاوروبيه
ايضا هنالك اتفاقيه الحبوب عبر البحر
الاسود قد يعني
اللي في رايها السابق وتعارض هذا
التخفيف في تمرير الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود
او حتى يعني همم تمرير الحبوب من مناطق
اخرى وبالتالي هذا ايضا يضغط على الاقتصاد
العالمي بشكل كامل اعتقد بان خيارات روسيا
محدوده وهذا ملحوظ لان لغايه الان لا يوجد
ردود حقيقيه فعليه ولهذا نرى الاسعار
منخفضه في الاسواق العالميه ولهذا هنالك
بوادر لنجاح الخطه الامريكيه في همم
السقوف السعوديه القصوى للنفط الروسي نعم
طبعا اوكرانيا كانت تريد لهذا السقف ان
ينزل الى الى 30 دولار على اساس ان ذلك
سيسرع في تدمير الاقتصاد الروسي كما قال
مدير مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني همم سيد سيد
رؤوف نائب رئيس الوزراء همم الكسندر نوفاك
قال لن تصدر النفط ولو تضرنا الى تخفيض
الانتاج ولكن هناك من يقول تخفيض الانتاج
في حداد مضر لروسيا لانه سيجعل الضرر يلحق
بمنشات النفطيه نتيجه هذا التخفيض
ولكن روسيا يتعود على تخفيض الانتاج
تماشيا مع الناجي الذي تمارسه مجموعه
التي كانت تمارسها عليها الولايات المتحده
والدول الغربيه الاخرى في محاوله لاقناعها
بضروره زياده انتاج النفط همم
يعني همم همم من اعضاء همم مجموعه توب
بلوس وفقا على هذه المطالب وهذا يعني ان
موقفها لا يمكن القول انها تؤيد روسيا
لكنها تتفهم موضوعيا الصعوبات الاقتصاديه
التي ربما صار تؤدي اليها همم خطوات
اراميه الى زياده الانتاج وهذا احتماما ان
الدول التي بادررت بتحديد السقف ربما لم
تفكر في افاق بعيده المدى وتداعيات بعيده
المدى لهذه الخطوه التي كما يقول
المراقبون حتى في دول الغربيه يمكن ان
تؤدي الى زياده حاده لاسعار النفطه التي
قد تصل الى 100 دولار مقابل البرميل او ما
فوق ذلك وهذا بتبيعه الحال سينعكس سلبا
ليس على روسيا وانما على دول الغربيه في
المقام الاول التي ستتضرر هي بنتيجه هذه
القفزه الهائله
يمكن ان تجري باسعار النفط وبالتالي الدول
التي بادرت
بتحديد هذا السقف ستضطر الى همم شراء
النفط باسعار عاليه اعلى بكثير من ما كانت
عليه عندما كانت تتعامل وتتعاون مع روسيا
نعم سنخوض اكثر في تداعيات هذا القرار
بالنسبه للاسواق العالميه ولكن لو بقينا
في الموقف الروسي سيد همم
نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي سيد نوفاك ايضا
قال سنضطر الى تغيير سلاسل التوزيع
بالنسبه
الروسي هل هذه عمليه سهله
وليد 69
ان تحقيق لها ولكن لابد ان تتذكر
بسبب عقوبات السابقه
هذا التمني همم
وبالتالي هناك فعلا خطر ارتفاع الاسعار
اخرى مهمه سيد شوبكي هو ان روسيا لا تمتلك
في الوقت الحالي مثل ما راينا في التقرير
الاسطول البحري الذي يسمح لها بالتحكم
بالكامل في تسويق نفطها الى اي مدى هذا
سيعرقل اي موقف روسي معارض للخطوه
نعم تماما المؤشرات تدل على ان روسيا
مشترك ناقلات نفط حوالي 100 ناقله قد تكون
اقل حتى من نصف حاجتها لنقل نفسها
وبالتالي هي ستلجا الى اسطول النقل الغربي
وشركات التامين الغربي وبالتالي نصف نفطها
سيكون تحت السقوف الشعريه الموجوده حاليا
وبالتالي هذا ايضا سيدفع روسيا الى بيع
نفطها باسعار اقل من السقوف الشعريه او
بالسقوف الشعريه بالتالي ايضا
العقوبات التي فرضت من الاتحاد الاوروبي
على النفط الروسي وجدت السقوف الشعريه
لمعالجه اثارها الغرب والدول الغربيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعه السبع تعلمت من
العقوبات السابقه التي كانت تنعكس سلبا
على الجانب الغربي واجابا على الارادات
الروسيه وعلى جانب الروسي لذلك درست هذه
العقوبات بعنايه والسقوف الشعريه جاءت
لضبط الاسعار ومعالجه اي خلل قد يقرا على
الاسواق او صدمه ترفع استعرض النفط لذلك
ايضا نرى بان السقوف الشعريه عالجت اي
ارتفاعات في الاسواق حتى مع تخفيف القيود
في الصين وتوقع ارتفاع الاسعار وتوقع ايضا
ارتفاع الاسعار مع بدء نفاذ العقوبات
الاوروبيه على النفط الروسي الى حوالي
المئه دولار البرميل نرى الان النفط ينخفض
ويخسر كل مكاسبه في العام 2022 ويعود الى
الان اقل من 77$ برميل برنت هذا ما اريد
ان اوضحه وكذلك ايضا همم يعني انخفاض
الدولار في همم سعر النفط الروسي يعني
خساره اثنين مليار دولار سنويا للايرادات
الروسيه خمسه دولار
معدل النفط الروسي 65 الى 60 السقوف
الشعريه يعني هذا خمسه دولار في كل برميل
ويعني هذا 10 مليار دولار من الايرادات
السنويه لروسيا هذا قصير قليل والتاثيرات
بسيطه على الايرادات الروسيه وبالتالي همم
هنا يعني تاتي الموازنه في تسعير السقوف
الشعريه للنفط الروسي بحيث لا تؤثر على
الامدادات الروسيه الى الاسواق وتضبط
الاسعار في الاسواق وبالتالي قدر الامكان
ربما لها مراجعه طبعا في التاسعه عشر من
يناير القادم او منتصف في يناير ومراجع كل
شهرين هذه السقوف في مرحله قادمه عندما
تمتص الاسواق صدمه همم الحظر على النفط
الروسي الى اوروبا وتمتص صدمه السقوف
الشعريه ربما تلجا الدول الجي 7
والاتحاد الاوروبي واستراليا الى تخفيض
اخر على السقوف الشعريه حسب متطلبات
الاسعار في الفتره القادمه ولكن واضح مثل
ما قال سيد رؤوف يعود اليه مره اخرى واضع
الناموس وراهم كثيرا على تسويق نفطها الى
الصين والى الهند وربما ايضا الى الى
تركيا واشارت قبل الخليل بان هذه الصادرات
زادت بنسبه الثلث ولكن هل يمكن لموسكو ان
تراهن على ذلك فقط وان يكون ذلك هو خيارها
الاساسي
لا بطبيعه الحال لا يمكن ان يكون ذلك
خيارها الاساسي انا قلت احد الخيرات
المحتمله بالمناسبه هناك نقطه اخرى قلما
يذكرها في معرض تحليل هذه الظاهره او
تدعيات تحديدا همم سعر النفط بستين دولارا
وهو ان قواعد الاتحاد الاوروبي تنص على ان
همم على انه اذا كان تقرير النفط الروسي
قد جرى خارج اراضي روسيا في اراضي الدول
الاخرى فالمصافي الواقع في هذه الدول
والتي تقوم بهذه العمليه فان النفط الروسي
الذي يكون الروسيا بالمعنى القانوني لهذا
المستوى وبالتالي هذا ربما احد الطرق التي
سوف تتيحه لموسكو الالتفاف على تداعيات
العقوبات المفروضه عليها او تثقيف الاسعار
ب60$ وبالتالي روسي لديها ربما خيارات
اخرى ولكنها موسكو لا تسرع في الكشف عنها
حتى ليه يعني تجعل الدول الاوروبيه تعيد
نظارها في تكتيكها وربما سياستها وتتخذ
وتلجا الى اجراءات اخرى همم سواء يعني في
ظل مراجعه الاسعار او مراجعه هذا القرار
كل شهرين او حتى ربما قبل انقضاء هذه
المهله اذا كانت مشكله تريد ان تكشف كل
الاوراق الدكتور بروسلي في لندن بالنسبه
للدول التي اتخذت هذا القرار ما اسوا ما
يمكن ان ترد به موسكو على قرارها
قد تكون تطوره
الدول الناميه التي تعتمد دائما على
شفافيه السوق الحره همم هناك همم ظاهره
همم سيد شوبكي في عمان
وهي ان موسكو دائما ما تعمل الى التقليل
او التهوين من العقوبات التي همم تتعرض
لها عقوبات سابقه وعقوبات في في مجالات
مختلفه هل تعتقد بان هذه المره ايضا هذا
التهوين ليس في محله ربما
نعم تماما يعني هذا هو الوصف الصحيح
العقوبات الاخيره السقوف الشعريه على وجه
الخصوص اعتقد بانها جاءت لتسهيل مرور
النفط الروسي الى الاسواق ولزياده امدادات
روسيا من النفط الاسواق وهذا قالته وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه بصراحه باننا سنكون
سعيدين بشراء النفط الروسي من قبل الهند
ومن دول اخرى لذلك همم هذا الامر ايضا
سيخفض الاسعار وهذا الامر
سي يدعم الاقتصاد العالمي هو الدول
الناميه خارج الاتحاد الاوروبي طبعا لان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعني حضر النفط الروسي
بشكل كامل الامر المهم الاخر ايضا بان
مركز الهند والصين مشترين الرئيسيين لان
النفط الروسي سيكون المركزهم التفاوضي
افضل في تخفيضات النفط التي تجري على
تخفيضات السعر التي تجعلنا النفط الروسي
وسيكون الفضل هنا ليس لك منحه مقدمه من
روسيا الى هذه الدول سيكون الفضل للسقوف
الشعريه اي ان صاحب الفضل ستكون الاتحاد
الاوروبي وجي 7 في من ناحيه اخرى همم يعني
الضربه الثالثه التي ننتظرها في السقوف
الشعريه
والحذر على مشتقات النفطيه في الخامس من
فبراير القادم هذه هذا الحظر وهذا الاجراء
ايضا سيكون صعب على الجانبين على الجانب
الروسي وعلى جانب الاوروبي ايضا لابد ان
اذكر بان طبعا همم
الاتحاد الاوروبي والجي 7 الولايات
المتحده على وجه الخصوص بهذه الخطوه تكون
قد نازعت اوبتك بلس في السيطره على اسعار
النفط العالميه هي الان تحدد سقوف في
الاسعار وتسيطر على اسعار النفط العالميه
وربما يكون هذا الاجراء نواه لكارتين جديد
من المشتريين يحددون به اسعار ليس فقط
النفط الروسي بل اسعار نفوط اخرى في
العالم نعم نعم هناك همم حديث همم سيد
سيدي رؤوف بان همم هذا الكلام على الاقل
رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في الدومه يقول
هذا القرار يصب في مصلحه الولايات المتحده
لان هي التي ستستفيد وهي التي ستصبح اكثر
ثراءا بحكم مبيعات النفط المقبله وربما
باسعار اكبر من من العاده هل تعتقد بان
هذا هو ابرز نتيجه
يمكن توقعها من من القرار
انا ليعتقد بانه ابرز نتيجه يمكن همم
توقعها نتيجه لهذا القرار ونحن في الحقيقه
من المبكر جدا ان نتحدث عن ذلك لابد ان
يمر وقت معين حتى
سيكون بالامكان ربما تحليل همم كل تداعيات
الناتجه عن هذه الخطوه ومن ثم ربما
التفكير في امور تتعلق بكيفيه الخروج من
الاسماء التي يمكن ان تصيب كل الاطراف
طبعا التي لها علاقه بهذا الموضوع سواء
اوروبيه او غيرها
وبالتالي همم لابد طبعا من مرور وقت معين
كما قلت بالنسبه لروسي يبدو انها تضع عده
طرق والديها استراتيجيه واضحه تماما لانه
وحسب قول نائب رئيس الوزراء
الذي شغل في سابق منصب وزير الطاقه هناك
خطه سوف تعل روسيا قريبا ولا شك ان هذه
الخطوه ستتضمن اجراءات دقيقه ومعينه ردا
على تسقيف الاسعار من قبل الاتحاد
الاوروبي واضح تماما ان الامور لا تع- لن
تعود الى طبيعتها على الاقل على المدى
القريب والمتوسط
وبالتالي على روسيا ان تتكيف مع الظروف
الحاليه وتتعلم ربما او تحاول اجابه طرق
اخرى ل- اا التعويذه عن الخسائر المحتمله
التي يمكن ان تلحق باقتصادها نتيجه لهذه
الخطوه ههه الكل الان سيدروس يقول من
الصعب التحكم في سلعه مثل النفط وخاصه وان
العالم مقبل على فصل الشتاء وبالتالي
الحسابات الاوروبيه وحسابات مجموعه الدول
السبعه مع استراليا قد لا تذهب
بالدقه التي يريدونها يعني السوق ستكون له
احكام خاصه في تحديد السعر وربما يرتفع
السعر
النفط في العالم
وترتبك الحسابات
الغاز
بروسيا عن اوروبا
كل مسارات الغاز
لانه لو اخذنا همم روسيا اكبر مصدر واذا
حاول تقليد صادرات فمن الدول الاخرى
السعوديه
هددت اي ناقلات للنفط تحمل نفطا روسيا
وترفع على من اخر همم للتموين هذا التحذير
والتهديد برايك سيعطي مفعولا واضحا
ااه مره اخرى
ان روسيا قد اشترت بعض الانقلات النفط
وفعلا وقد تستخدم ناقلات الاوروبيه
لاستمرار
بعملها بالشفافيه
وكما قلت سابقا
الى السوق الرماديه او الظل هو ان هناك
همم على العراق
السوداء دائما تزداد وتزدهر عندما تكون
هناك عقوبات ولكن هل سيؤدي هذا الوضع
السيد الشوبكي الى ارتفاع حتمي في اسعار
النفط في الفتره المقبله حضرتك
ضيفنا ايضا من موسكو الى ان الامر قد يصل
الى 100 دولار
للبرميل الواحد هل هل هذا حتمي
اممم في الظروف الحاليه لا قال لشعار
ستنخفض لكن اذا ما قررت روسيا تفضيل
مصالحها السياسيه على مصالحها الاقتصاديه
وفي هذا يكون امر قاتل للاقتصاد الروسي في
حين خفضت انتاج تقريبا 2 مليون برميل من
الانتاج اليومي الاسعار سترتفع سترتفع
كثيرا اكثر من 100 الى 150 دولار لكن في
الظروف الحاليه الاسعار تنقبض يعني ان
اقول ايضا بان العقوبات جاءت مخففه حتى في
الحظر والسقوف السعريه لا يوجد هنالك
عقوبات دائما حتى السفن التي تخرق هذه
العقوبات همم في تحميل نفط روسي باعلى من
السقوف الشعريه فقد توقيف 90 يوم عن شركات
التامين والبنيه التحتيه الاوروبيه
سابقا كان ال- كانت العقوبات في حجز ار
سيده ولائحه سوداء
ويعني عقوبات دائما لهذا اقول بان الامر
الحالي ايضا ملبي لحاجه الخزانه السعر عند
60 دولار هي هو سعر المعادله للموازنه
الروسيه اقل ما يمكن من سعر المعادله
لموازيه الروسيه وبالتالي روسيا لن تكون
يعني في عجز عن تصدير همم النفط الذي كان
يذهب الى اوروبا فقط بتبادل الادوار ونقله
الى القاره الاسيويه وهذا ما يريده الغرب
بالفعل لكن ستكون همم كلف اعلى اذا ما
استخدمت سفن قديمه وسيكون ايضا بكله شحن
اعلى خاصه اذا ما مرت في قناه السويس
مرورا الى همم
الناحيه الاسيويه وبالتالي الان هنالك بعض
الدول التي هي همم يعني في خارج هذه
العقوبات واخذت الثقه منها دول اوروبيه
منها مطله على البحر مثل كرواتيا وابو
بلغاريا ودول تاخذ النفط الروسي عبر
الانابيب من خط دروبه واليابان ايضا هنالك
استثناء للنفط الذي تستورده عبر السليل
واعتقد بان رد الذي يتوقع الجميع لن ياتي
في الاثناء سيدتي رؤوف الخبراء يقولون بان
الدول الناميه ربما ستكون هي اكبر مستفيد
على الاقل في الوقت الحالي طالما اسعار
النفط ستكون منخفضه بهذا التثقيف هل هل
فعلا همم
تشاطر هذا هذا الرئيس
نعم الى درجه معينه هذا شاطر هذا الراي
الى ان همم هذه الدول طبعا الدول الناميه
ستكون مستفيده كما ان الدول حتى دول الغني
المتقدمه منها الصين على سبيل المثال
تستفيد الان وحتى قبل ذلك لانها همم حسب
بعض الانباء همم تطلب من روسيا همم
تخفيضات معينه لاسعارها للنفط وتستفيد من
ذلك وتزيد من كمياتها للنفضه الذي تشتريه
من روسيا اعتقد بان نفس السياسه همم
تمارسه الهند وربما عدد من الدول الاخرى
ومنها طبعا دول جديده نوعا ما ذو الاسيويه
وربما حتى دول افريقيا همم هناك انبات
تفيد بان روسيا بدات الاستعدادات للقمه
الروسيه الافريقيه التي من المقرر عقدها
في صيف العام المقبل وربما ضمن حسابات
روسيا اي التعويله على هذه الدول كي شركاء
جدد ولكن طبعا اا الامر همم مرهون ايضا
بقدرتها على شراء النفط الروسي دون الدخول
في مساله القروض التي يمكن ان تطلبها من
روسيا مقابل شرائها للنفط لو نتوقف قليلا
دكتور بروس في لندن همم عند همم اوبل كلاس
كيف تتوقع ان تتصرف افقي بلس الان همم من
ناحيه هي ليست قادره على تعويض النقص الذي
سوف غياب النفط الروسي ولكن ليس بامكاني
ايضا ان تقف مكتوبه الايدين امام هذه
التطورات الاخيره
لا تشعر بقلق شديد
لان هذه قد يؤدي الى التاثيرات على دول
اخرى اذا ما نظر اليها انها ليست صديق او
والديه مع الاتحاد الاوروبي وجي 7
اذاقونا جدا
بفضل الجانب التكنولوجيا من العقوبات فلو
انك صادرات روسيا انخفضت في اوروبا
وبالتالي كل ما على اوفيق ان تفعله ان
تجلس وتستريح وستنتقل الاسعار الى مستويات
غير مقبوله وبالتالي تعود الامور لامرها
وهل يمكنها ان تفعل ذلك بسهوله سيدروس
امين نطنط
تغيير الكوتا الحصص هذا امر زاد الاسعار
اكثر مئه دولار فاعتقد نعم اوبك يمكن
تفاعلوا مع الاسواق وزياده الانتاج
والسعوديه فعلا لديها من القدرات الاضافيه
او الاحتياط وبالتالي النتيجه
الثاني فائزه
ماذا تتوقع السيد شوبكي من اوبك بلس في
ضوء
افرزته هذه القرارات من من اوضاع
نعم هي شبهه اعلنت بانها ستنتظر حتى تتضح
الصوره سواء من تباطؤ الاقتصادي العالمي
ومن الردود الفعل سواء في
المعروض الروسي في الاسواق او في الطلب
الصيني من جاء من ناحيه اخرى فبالتالي هي
يعني بالتاكيد ربما تستعيد موقعها للسيطره
على اسعار النفط لانها يعني قالت في
اجتماع الاخير بانها سترقم الاسواق وفي
حاجه الى تخفيض او زياده الانتاج لن يعني
لن تتوالى عن ذلك اول مراجعه ل- همم
اللجنه الفنيه في اوبك بلس ستكون بعد
شهرين اجتماع القادم سيكون في الاول من
يونيو القادم بعد سته اشهر وبالتالي اي رد
فعل من اوبك بلس لا اعتقد بانه سيكون قريب
الشرت قبل قليل سيد شوبكي
لي موضوع انه الخامس من فبراير يفترض ان
يقع ااا تسقيف لي المنتجات النفطيه هذه
المره ليس فقط للنفط وانما للمنتجات
النفطيه هل هذا سيعقد الوضع اكثر في
الاسواق العالميه
نعم اعتقد بان وقع مثل يعني هذا الاجراء
سيكون اكبر سواء على روسيا او على اوروبا
ذاتها اوروبا التي تستورد 60% من حاجتها
من الديزل من روسيا وبالتالي هذا الديزل
الان مرتفع الثمن في الاسواق وحاجتها الى
الديزل مرتفعه في فصل الشتاء واعتقد بانه
سيكون وقعه على اوروبا اكبر منه على روسيا
في العقوبات القادمه لكن الاجراءات الثلاث
سواء السقوف الشعريه العقوبات الاوروبيه
على النفط او المقبل من العقوبات على
مشتقات الروسيه هي ردود على خطبه روسيا
الاولى في قطع انجازات الغاز الموجهه الى
اوروبا نستطيع ان نقول الان بان حرب
الطاقه قد اشتعلت فعليا ما بين اوروبا
الدول الغربيه من ناحيه من روسيا من ناحيه
ثانيه نعم هل هل سيزداد الوضع صعوبه السيد
سيدي رب بالنسبه لموسكو عندما تدخل قصه
تسقيف سعر المنتجات النفطيه فيص اا الوضع
اكثر تعقيدا سقف للنفط وسقف للمنتجات
النفطيه وهذا ربما لا تستطيع موسكو ان
تتحمله على على جبهتين صح التعبير
انا اعتقد بان روسيا بدات تستعد لميس لهذا
التطور لمثل هذا السيناريو ولديه قطط ولكن
كما قلت فهي لا تسرع كما كما انها لا تسرع
الكشف عن كل اوراق فيما يتعلق بالرد على
تسقيف بسعر الضغط فهي ايضا لتصرف في الكشف
عن رضودها المحتمله على هذه الاحتمالات
الثلاثيه اذا كانت مجتمعه وكان يمكنها ان
تؤثر بهذا الشكل او ذلك على حاله الاقتصاد
الروسي بتبيعه الحال روسيا لديها خطط
وروسيا كانت منذ بدايه العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه كما تسمى همم تستعيد وتدرس كل
الاحتمالات المتعلقه
بالتدعيات الثقيله من قبل الحزم السابقه
وربما الحزم التي يتم الاعدادات لها من
العقوبات على الاقتصاد الروسي همم هناك
همم مجموعات وفي فرق خاصه بداخل الحكومه
الروسيه وهي تشتغل بهذا الموضوع انها تضع
همم مختلف الخطط والاحتمالات وهي متابعه
يوميا همم حاله الاسواق والوضع في
الاقتصاد العالمي وتداعيات ما يحدث الان
على
الوضع الاقتصادي العالمي وطبعا الاقتصاد
الروسي وبالتالي اعتقد بان روسيا نوعا ما
ستكون جاهزه للتعامل مع كل هذه الامور
وتدايات الناتجه عن تسقيط الاسعار وعن
ايضا فرض همم يعني نفس القرار على
المشتقات النفطيه ايه اعتبارا من شهر
فبراير من العامل مثل ما صرت سيد همم وهنا
اسال همم الدكتور
لا تريد ان تعلن عن كامل خطتها في الرد
على الخطوه الغربيه ما اسوء ما يمكن ان
تتخذه موسكو من اجراءات للرد على هذه
الخطوه وستجزعج الدول الغربيه وقد
حساباتها بالكامل
بان اوروبا ضعيفه في حرب الطاقه هذه لاننا
ننتج فقط 10% من الغاز واقل من 10% من
النفط وبالتالي ثم موسكو
حقيقه
لانها تلعب
سيكون صعب جدا علينا
ان نجتمع حلول وان اي شيء
اذا خفضت كميات الصادرات في
تصدرنا في منتصف الصيف الشتاء البارد جدا
والطاقه النوويه في فرنسا لا تعمل بكامل
طاقتها وبالتالي يتقل لل هذا يعني في ان
سيكون لدينا المزيد من ازمه الطاقه وهذا
يؤدي ما يمكن السبت الى الارهاق الاوكراني
وبالتالي السياسيون سوف يواجهون شيئا
مواطنيهم يقولون لهم نحن سعداء ما يحصل في
قناه مساعدات اوكرانيا وهذا فعلا ما يؤثر
اذا وصلنا الى هذه النقطه سيدروس هل تعتقد
بامكانيه مراجعه هذه القرارات المتخذه ضد
روسيا
نوع
قمنا بهذه اجراءات لا يمكن التراجع عنها
ولهذا السبب اللي علينا ان نفكر به بشكل
دقيق في الخطوات القادمه ولذلك مره اخرى
استخدم مثال للغاز لم نكون مستعدين لذلك
كان علينا ان نصارى بشكل طارئ السفر
الطريق
المزيد من القوه في هذه النظام كل هذه
القرارات
الغرض منها طبعا تقليل ال- ال- ال- او
الاضرار بالمجهود الحربي الروسي في
اوكرانيا العقوبات السابقه زائد العقوبات
الحاليه المتعلقه بالتسقيف النفط ولاحقا
تثقيف منتجات النفط هل ستدفع موسكو الى
مراجعه موقفها برايك فيما يتعلق باوكرانيا
طبعا
اه انا ليه اعتقد ذلك لان روسيا لين تتاثر
بطبيعه الحال بين انعكاسات هذه الاجراءات
التي تتضمنها الحزم المختلفه من العقوبات
على الاقتصاد الروسي وحتى اذا كان هناك
تاثير السلبي فروسيه ربما قريبا سوف تجد
طرقا كفيله للخروج عنها والتعويض عن
خسائلها بهذا الشكل او ذاك ونحن بتبيه
الحال واقول ذلك ربما للمره الرابعه في
هذه الحلقه روسيا لا تسرع في الكشف عن
اوراقك وهذا هو احد الاساليب المفضله
للسياسه الاقتصاديه الروسيه لانه له علمت
الدول الغربيه بكيفيه الرد الروسي لما
لاجي هاتي الى ربما طرق وبداء الى اخرى
لتاثير الاكثر ضررا على الاقتصاد الروسي
وهمم بالتالي فليذا التكتيكا الروسي ما
يبررها من ناحيه الخطوط القادمه
والتداريات والاحتما التي قد تلجا اليها
روسيا في دراستها وتعاملها مع هذا الملف
في ضوء كل هذا المشهد سيد عامر الشوبكي ما
اسوا ما يمكن ان يحدث نتيجه هذه المناكفه
بين قوسين في العقوبات والرد المتوقع
الروسي وغير ذلك من التداعيه
نعم اسوا ما يمكن ان يحدث هو ان تتخذ
روسيا جميع خياراتها مره واحده تقطع الغاز
عن اوروبا تخفض انتاجها وتقطع او توقف
اتفاقيه تسهيل مرور الحبوب من البحر
الاسود في هذه الحاله قد تقلب الطاوله على
الجانب الاخر جانب الغربي والاتحاد
الاوروبي وتفشل جميع خطاطه وترتفع الاسعار
النفط عدا ان عوده ايضا معدلات التضخم
المرتفعه واسعار الاغذيه المرتفعه في
العالم كل هذا الان ايضا قد تسيطر عليه
الولايات المتحده على وجه الخصوص في
محاوله تاخير عجله الاقتصاد العالمي برفع
اسعار الفائده هنالك رفع بعد اسبوع على
اسعار الفائده من الفئران الامريكي وربما
تنتظر ايضا في ربعين من العام 2023
ارتفاعات اخرى على اسعار الفائده كل هذا
ايضا قد يساعد على التخفيف من حده وطئه اي
تصرف تتخذه روسيا من
لجانب الجهه الغربيه طبعا الاقتصاد الروسي
بقدر ما هو قوي الا انه مكشوف ايرادات
الروسيه تاتي معظمها من الطاقه والحرب
الان تاتي من الجانب الغربي في مواجهه
مصادرات الطاقه الروسيه فلذلك ما زالت
الابواب مفتوحه على كل الاحتمالات رغم ان
بعضها قد لا يكون متاحا امام روسيا واعتقد
بانه انتحار لروسيا اذا ما اقدمت على
تخفيض انتاجها تخفيض اراداتها وبالتالي
ايضا ستتحقق الغايه الغربيه في تخفيف قدره
روسيا على المواصله في حربها على اوكرانيا
وتغذيه الالتها العسكريه همم سؤال اخير
همم دكتور بروس في لندن هل من الوارد ان
تفشل الخطه الغربيه في موضوع النفط
وعقوبات روسيا الاخيره
ولد
شديده وقويه في الخطه افضل خطه هي فرض
الحظر كما فعلنا على النفط وعلى منتجات
النفطيه والغاز ولكن كما تعلمون لا نستطيع
ان نفعل ذلك لان النفق والغاز الروسي
مطلوبان على مستوى العالمي وبالتالي خطه
الاحتياطيه لخطي الاحتياطيه لخطه
الاحتياطيه وبالتالي لا اعتقد الناس
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور استاذ الاقتصاد في
جماعه معهد العلوم السياسيه في باريس شكرا
لضيفنا من عمان
في شؤون النفطي والطاقه وشكرا لضيفنا من
موسكو
وكالعاده ننتقل الى تغريدات حول موضوع هذه
الحلقه ونبدا بتغريده لرئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه ارسل لافندر لاين تقول فيها
يشهد الاقتصاد الروسي حاله من الفوضى على
نحو متزايد سنبقي الضغط عاليا
وسنقف الى جانب اوكرانيا اليوم وغدا ومهما
استغرق الامر اما مفاوض السياسه الخارجيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبي فيقول بعد الطعام
والجوع قرر بوتن الان تحويل الشتاء الى
السلاح
يريد قطع الكهرباء والتدفئه وامدادات
المياه لملايين المدنيين في انحاء
اوكرانيا نحن نرد بالحزمه التاسعه من
العقوبات ضد اولئك الذين لهم دور فعال في
هذه الحرب الوحشيه موقع بلومبرج انرجي
نشرت تغريد جاء فيها يبدو ان المواجهه
بشان العقوبات وقواعد التامين التي اوقفت
ناقلات النفط في مضيق البوسفور تتصاعد كما
ترك ملايين البراميل عالقه في المضائق
التركيه
رودريغو فلاميزار وهو خبير في شؤون الطاقه
ووزير الطاقه الكولومبي السابق يقول ربما
تحرز اوكرانيا تقدما ضد روسيا لكن تحديدا
سقفا لاسعار على لاسعار الواردات النفط
الخام الروسيه لا يعطل الايرادات الروسيه
من مبيعات النفط على الاطلاق في الواقع
مئات ناقلات النفط الروسي تبيعه اكثر من
اي وقت النظام ونختم بتغريده للدكتور
سليمان الخطاب وهو كاتب سعودي مختص في
شؤون الطاقه يقول الصين تشتري النفط
الروسي ب 68 دولار طبعا بخصم كبير مقابل
البرنت ولكن احسن من السقف السعري المفروض
من الغرب وهو 60 دولار هذا يؤكد ما قالته
روسيا بانها لن تبيع النفط لاي دوله تطبق
سقف ولكننا سن اعطي خصما حسب الاسواق
والظروف واعلنت اليابان التزامات التام
بالسياسه السقف الساري يعني لا نفطر روسيا
لليابان
بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه موعدنا يتجدد الخميس
المقبل باذن الله وحتى ذلك الحين دمتم في
رعايه الله والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]